trong cuộc chả lời phòng bánh với từ trên lời graf
tầm thông thông viên đoàn trong trở biến
có chính tình đăng xem xét khả năng giúp khỏi tụi trước khi bước bắt đặt đi dương nha tổ
ông cho sang, đêm mình này chứ thì hiện mức độ hỗ trợ cần thiết
đối với trên sĩ của sự có nghĩa nhà bởi răng
nhà lãnh gạo mi nhận định nha tổ không đa bứng kiệ tọc
về vai trọng anh ninh
đồng thời chân sang cứ đồng mình cho ông cần chủ đồng hơn
trong việc bảo vệ lợi e cuối mình
đã biệt liên quan đến bảo đảm anh năng lượng tới bình thông mut
trong khi đó ông lại trừng mình mắt khu đ入 biểu của mình
còn quan điểm cần xem xét lại quan hệ với nha tổng sau xuân bộ
ông cho sang, một số cuối ra cho ông chưa tạo đủ kiện đầy đủ cho mình
sự giống căng tự quan sự phục vụ các mục tiêu trị lợp
về phía các nước cho ông như cuối ra thì tục giữa lập trường thận trọng
chưa tham ra chự tế và có hỏi đồng cuối sự tại trường đăng
giờ qua rất nhiều đình, các bạn này có thể làm sao tăng xức kép được về quan hệ suyên đại tây dương trong thời gian tới